i just need to
clear my head and start fresh
[Music]
gotta be unique but gotta blend in hide
my inner geek and keep pretending
gotta keep them laughing though i'm only
having gotta put a show until i know
they like me
gotta be aloof make a good impression
gotta hide the proof of my
self-expression
never be revealing gotta be appealing
suddenly i'm feeling like i'm getting so
small breaking into little pieces
losing power getting weaker gotta
do whatever pleases till they let me
in so we try to be more than enough
trying to be strong and tough try to be
something we're not trying to fit a
different flat
proving we're bold
[Music]
gotta keep
[Music]
but i know there's nobody like me
[Music]
try to be something we're
[Music]
[Music]
we would all be free
but he
[Music]
what was divided so that's how it
has to be but if we try to uncover
what's real
i'm already strong and tough put down
our
[Music]
gotta be unique but gotta blend in hide
my inner geek and keep pretending
gotta keep them laughing so i'm only
having gotta put a show until i know
they like me
no more trying too hard to be me
[Music]
[Applause]
cause it's their turn to try to see
[Music]
me
you